[Musik]
Bilder aus Deutschland nach der
Präsidentenwahl in der Türkei im Mai
letzten Jahres feiern bundesweit
10000ende türkischstämmige Menschen
euphorisch den Wahlsieg von Präsident
[Musik]
Erdogan der türkische Autokrat schafft
es immer wieder hier Zande die Massen zu
begeistern kommt nun der nächste Schritt
um sich weiter politischen Einfluss in
Deutschland und Europa zu
sichern anbieten dafür würde sich die
neuegründete politische Vereinigung d
auf Platz 1 der Liste für die Europawahl
steht fati Singal bis vor kurzem
Führungsmitglied der UID eine
Lobbyorganisation von Erdogans Partei
AKP die Kritik findet er unbegründet mit
Erdogan habe da aber nichts zu tun sie
waren ja bei der uide in führender
Position ist das dann glaubwürdig wir
suchen andere Herausforderung wir
möchten über Probleme mit von Menschen
sprechen mit türkischer
Zuwanderungsgeschichte mit
muslimischenem background was für
Probleme sie innerhalb der deutschen
Gesellschaft haben wir möchten uns über
latenten Rassismus unterhalten und
deswegen haben wir die sonst Vereinigung
da warründet versteht FTI Singal hat als
UID Funktionär jahrelang die
Wahlberechtigten für den türkischen
Präsidenten
mobilisiert wer wird der nächste
Präsident der
Türkei auch die anderen dava
Spitzenkandidaten haben klare
Verbindungen nach
Ankara mustafaoldasch war Funktionär der
Organisation Milli Görisch die vom
Verfassungsschutz als islamistisch
eine von ihm geführte Hilfsorganisation
wurde verboten nachdem rauskam das gelda
auch an die
hamasflossen und schließlich Ali Isan
Funktionär bei ditip dem
türkischmuslimischen Dachverband der der
Religionsbehörde dianet in Ankara
untersteht und die Präsident
Erdogan hinter dava stecke die türkische
Regierung sagt CDU Politiker Ali
to und die türkischen Medien die von
Erdogan kontrolliert werden die
gleichgeschaltet sind
werden massiv diese Partei unterstützen
und ich befürchte noch mehr
gesellschaftliche Spaltung durch diese
neue Partei in Deutschland dava will
sich an alle Muslime richten die sich
angeblich von der deutschen Politik
nicht berücksichtigt fühlten das größte
Wählerpotenzial sieht sie bei den
türkeistemmigen etwa 2,8 Millionen leben
in Deutschland davon haben rund 1,5
Millionen die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit durch die
Neuregelung bei im Doppelpass könnten
mehr als eine Million potenzielle Wähler
dazu kommen sicherlich werden nicht alle
türkeistemmingen hier zu Lande dava
wählen der bayerische Ministerpräsident
sieht sich dennoch bestätigt wir
brauchen keine Beeinflussung von
außerhalb und deswegen soll die Ampel
auch noch mal über
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht nachdenken ob
diese schnelle Einbürgerung nicht noch
ein zusätzlicher Schub sein könnte
gerade für die Pläne von Erdogan wir
lehnen es jedenfalls ab kein Problem hat
Markus Söder dagegen mit dem
türkisch-muslimischen Dachverband auch
beim letzten Fastenbrechen besucht der
aus gerechnet
dietip es ist ein ganz großer
Unterschied ob man sich mit
Vereinen beschäftigt die auch für
Integration mit arbeiten oder ob man
umgekehrt er in die Situation kommt dass
eine Partei gegründet wird die
tatsächlich auf dem Befehl von Ankara
hört das kann nicht sein diep soll an
der Integration mitarbeiten deren Imame
nachweislich Erdogan Gegner
ausspionierten und die immer wieder
Propaganda für die Angriffskriege der
türkischen Armee machte
mein Appell an die CDU CSU ist statt
sich im Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
abzuarbeiten guckt mal in Eure eigenen
Reihen rein und nicht da so reden in der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit und den
türkischen Verein dann kuscheln das
machen fast alle deutschen Parteien auch
das muss man ein Ende haben von den SPD
Parteivorsitzenden war niemand zu einem
Interview zu dava bereit und der
Fraktionsvorsitzende zeigt sich auf
einer PK schmalebich ob diese Partei in
irgendeiner Form hier Relevanz bekommt
das werden in der Diskussion dann
sehenigentlich als Werbegesicht für
seine künftige Partei sagt uns fati
Singal wünsche er sich mesitösil der
nach massiver Kritik wegen seiner Nähe
zu Autokrat Erdogan von der
Nationalmannschaft zurücktrat und dann
Rassismus
Beklagte